à
[Musique]
bonsoir des enfants
c'est curieux nounours j'ai bien
l'impression que certains enfants sont
déjà au lit oh vous croyez que nicolas
et pimprenelle sont déjà couchés pas
trop qui ferait bien d'aller voir sans
faire de bruit le cheval aux
propos papaux
[Musique]
j'ai fini ma toilette et je viens ou ou
foot au rebut dû
[Musique]
vous faire plaisir manos nous lui avons
promis d'aller très vite au lycée soir
[Musique]
oh ça c'est gentil il faut toujours
faire plaisir à sa maman moi aussi quand
j'étais petit
je me souviens
quand je te petit
jeu
sous vivant
de banc
petit pas bon jury
un
petit
vent
faire les courses
il ya plus de là
on a tous
en nous
moi je
répondais
chic ou
maman joli haut
et vite jal
jusqu'à la berge bruit
quand j'ai été 10 heures
moore
rémy girard
[Musique]
en dehors
tu t'habilles est avec moi
je
répondeur
jeu
moine match truire au camp
bauchau vous le
savoir lire
écrire
[Musique]
ma soeur emilie à
jouer
à la barre
pour bon dans ce ton lors
je l'avais la vue
[Musique]
remontons
mais je n'oublie pas
que ma maman
a toujours été fier de moi
[Musique]
oh
oui vraiment
bien ce cours du numéro
faire plaisir
à sa chute
pas bon
[Musique]
où
en
[Musique]